Convert log base
4 of 2 equals 1/2
into an exponential equation.
So a logarithm
literally tells you--
so if we were to just look
at this part right over here,
a logarithm is just saying,
tell me the exponent
that I would have
to raise my base to,
that I would have to
raise 4 to, to get to 2.
So tell me the
exponent that I would
have to raise it to to get to 2.
And so this equation written
as a logarithmic equation says,
I need to raise 4 to the
1/2 power in order to get 2.
So if I wanted to write it
as an exponential equation,
I could literally just
say, well, if I raise 4--
and that's this 4
right over here.
That's my base-- to this
exponent, to the 1/2 power,
then that is going
to be equal to 2.
And we're done.
We've written the same equation
as an exponential equation.
The value of a logarithm--
this is saying,
what do I get if I raise
4 to the 1/2 power?
I get 2 if I raise
4 to the 1/2 power.
This is saying, what power do I
have to raise 4 to to get to 2?
And then that is equal to 1/2.
So a logarithm is
saying, what power
do I have to raise
the base to to get
what's inside the logarithm?
This says, what do I get to
when I raise 4 to the 1/2 power?